Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Prigioniera numero 18051972.
Incarcerata da quando è nata,
sono stati uccisi tutti i suoi figli.
Lei stessa condannata a morte,
nel momento nel quale
è stata ritenuta inutile.
Il suo nome era Marta.
Prigioniera 100276.
Incatenata da quando è nata,
sono stati uccisi tutti i suoi figli.
Alle sue mammelle, per anni,
attaccate delle pompe idrauliche.
Condannata a morte
nel momento nel quale
è stata ritenuta inutile.
Il suo nome era Emma.
Sono due madri tra le 60.000 madri
che sono state uccise
da quando ho cominciato questo discorso.
60.000.
L'uomo giustifica questo olocausto
definendolo un processo naturale,
necessario, normale.
Perché nella nostra cultura occidentale
questi sono semplicemente
degli anonimi animali di allevamento.
Sono nati per soffrire,
per essere uccisi, per nutrirci.
Vale però la pena ricordare
che questa è la primaria causa
di distruzione di questo pianeta:
inquinamento, cambio climatico,
distruzione delle risorse naturali.
Vale la pena, inoltre, sapere
che la metà del cibo
prodotto in questa maniera
è gettato via.
Trucidiamo ogni anno miliardi di animali
non per sfamare i popoli
che muoiono di fame,
bensì per buttarli nella pattumiera.
Senza contare poi il fatto
che grazie a questa alimentazione
[ci] sono milioni di persone
che soffrono di malattie:
obesità, diabete,
ed altre forme di malattia
relazionate direttamente
a questo tipo di alimentazione.
Ciononostante, io non sono qui oggi
per definire
come possiamo e dobbiamo nutrire
otto miliardi di umani.
Io qui oggi sono
per parlare degli innocenti
che non possono farlo al posto loro.
Come Max.
Come John.
Come Mike.
Come Albert.
Come Tami.
Come la Berta.
Ed infine, come Frederic.
Che non hanno nulla a che vedere
con la nostra alimentazione,
ma fanno parte dei milioni di animali
che noi trucidiamo per le loro pellicce,
per le nostre ricerche scientifiche,
per il nostro divertimento
o semplicemente per l'incuranza
che abbiamo verso la natura.
Questi non sono animali.
Queste sono persone!
Sì, perché il termine "persona",
da un punto di vista giuridico,
non ha nulla a che vedere
con il termine "umano",
che rappresenta il genere
della specie Sapiens Sapiens,
dell'ordine dei primati,
della classe dei mammiferi
alla quale noi apparteniamo.
Da un punto di vista giuridico,
la persona è un'entità senziente
capace di provare emozioni complesse,
come l'amore e la compassione.
Da un punto di vista giuridico,
la persona è colui, o colei ,
che prende decisioni autonome
della propria vita:
ha un passato, vive nel presente
e ha un futuro.
La persona desidera vivere
e desidera amare,
come desideravano vivere,
e amare, Marta ed Emma.
Sorprendentemente, nella Storia,
lo stato di persona è stato negato
anche agli esseri umani.
Per millenni, l'uomo bianco
ha negato questo stato all'uomo nero,
schiavizzando e uccidendo
milioni di uomini neri.
È grazie alle guerre,
che abbiamo sconfitto
questa piaga sociale chiamata schiavitù.
Poi abbiamo ritenuto illegittimo
limitare loro i diritti civili
e siamo in parte riusciti
anche a sconfiggere
la seconda piaga sociale,
chiamata razzismo.
Che nella forma più criminale
e meschina della storia
ha ucciso sei milioni di ebrei,
sotto la forma del nazismo.
Abbiamo anche inteso che la donna
non è affatto inferiore all'uomo maschio,
e oggigiorno nessuno veramente
può accogliere un consenso sociale
promuovendosi con discorsi maschilisti.
Questa piaga si chiama sessismo!
Pertanto, l'idea che la specie umana
sia superiore a tutto il creato
è anche lei una visione
distorta della realtà:
si chiama specismo,
e rappresenta forse
la più grande conquista sociale
che possiamo abbracciare
nei prossimi decenni.
L'idea che l'uomo
sia superiore contro la natura
è una visione alienata di noi stessi.
Noi non siamo questi mostri
che distruggono il pianeta Terra.
Noi siamo gli dèi di questo pianeta,
e come tali dobbiamo comportarci.
Non è possibile parlare, oggi,
di industria 4.0,
intelligenza artificiale,
realtà virtuale, genetica,
nanotecnologie, robotica,
e basare ancora
il nostro benessere sociale ed economico,
sulla distruzione
della vita dei più deboli.
Non si tratta neanche di creare
e generare in noi un senso di colpa:
questo è un viaggio che non finisce mai,
quello di prendere coscienza
del reale potere dell'uomo.
Ci troviamo di fronte alla possibilità
di trascendere i nostri limiti,
perché quando capiremo
che noi siamo parte del creato,
e siamo i suoi difensori,
probabilmente sapremo ancora di più
che cosa vuol dire
l'essenza dell'essere umano,
e del suo potere.
Sono cosciente del fatto
che ci siano molte persone
che sono apertamente ostili
a questa visione liberale
dei diritti dell'uomo.
E degli animali.
E delle piante.
E allora non posso far altro
che chiederlo in ginocchio.
Abbiate misericordia di questo mondo,
perché senza di voi non lo salveremo mai!
L'infrastruttura di questo mondo
sono i cuori delle persone.
La "chiave di svolta" che stiamo cercando
si trova solo, ed esclusivamente,
dentro ciascuno di noi.
Solo ed esclusivamente agendo insieme
apriremo la porta del nostro futuro.
Grazie della vostra attenzione.
(Applausi)